this is the Intel nuc-13 extreme
codename Raptor Canyon it's literally
the most slimmest and most compact PC
we've ever seen it packs the latest 13th
gen I9 3900k with 32 gigabytes of ddr5
rep and an RTX 3080 TI with support for
triple slot 12 inch GPU hello RTX 4090
the Intel nuc-13 Xtreme will be
available in November and will be priced
starting from U.S 1179 we've managed to
snack ourselves a unit pretty early so
let's run some benchmarks and see how it
performs for both gaming and creating
for our first test God of War running 2K
on Ultra you can see that we have 120
FPS a few frame drops but not noticeable
let's try out shadow of a Tomb Raider
Benchmark and we are hitting more than
160 FPS at the highest quality at 2K the
pureget bench test for Premiere Pro and
let's see the results show that its
score is over 1500 loving the Intel
Raptor Canyon is definitely a beast of a
machine